these family and friends of murdered
journalist herbert lopez are gathering
for his wake he was a manager of a news
website in mexico's southern state of
oaxaca and was shot dead on thursday
this was a cruel act done without doubt
by unscrupulous people i think our
colleague didn't deserve that kind of
warning if that's what they wish to
convey by shooting him five times
prosecutors say two suspects were
arrested as they tried to leave the
murder scene lopez had received threats
before but he'd not joined a government
program that provides protection for
around 500 journalists his brother said
trust in institutions is falling
[Music]
lately we've fallen victim to
criminality to abuse of power situations
that are beyond our control as a media
worker i'm very worried i trust in the
authorities and ask them to do their job
as they should
lopez is the fifth journalist to be
murdered in mexico this year president
andres manuel lopez obrador says those
responsible will be brought to justice
it may be that these regrettable crimes
are committed but there is no impunity
zero impunity it is not the same as
before in all cases
reporters without borders says 90 of the
murders of journalists go unpunished in
mexico many reporters are killed for
working on stories about drug-related
violence or government corruption
mexico is one of the most dangerous
countries for journalists and we're seen
like that by the rest of the world we're
seen as a country where the authorities
are not able to contain these crimes and
end impunity we've been asked time and
again what's happening in mexico
journalists across mexico know the
dangers they face are rising and they're
urging the government to do much more to
protect them victoria gatenby al jazeera